[Music]
There Is No
Escape
[Music]
ever hello Internet welcome to film
Theory the show that'll be theorized
Rising day after day after day after day
after day and we don't know why let's
talk about the amazing digital circus
shall we you my friends stumbled into an
incredible world of Wonders where
anything can happen except for swearing
oh my God in case you aren't caught up
with this one this is the latest series
from the creative Geniuses over at
glitch Productions this one was written
produced and directed by Goose Works a
talented artist who also composed music
for both hasb been hotel and hell of a
boss and their creativity and experience
really come through with this one I got
to say you guys went crazy recommending
this one to us across comments GT live
and our subreddit and it's pretty darn
easy to see why between the amazing
animation Gable moments and incredible
cast of characters and a storyline
wrapped up in like 18 different layers
of mystery this is the perfect show for
us to dive into which means that if you
haven't watched the first full episode
yet go do it watch it after this Theory
though I'd be surprised if you hadn't
cuz this thing already has like 30
million views across the platform it is
doing Mighty well for itself but just so
we're all on the same page for today's
theories the follows a woman named pomy
who's thrust into a strange Digital
World styled after a circus alongside
five other humans Jax The Lovable jerk
ratha the sweet Optimist gangle who
can't hide her emotions zubal who's made
out of a bunch of random objects and
kinger who's been trapped there the
longest and has gone kind of crazy as a
result the whole circus is run by a ring
leader named Cain who according to the
show's website is a quote wacky Ai and
all of the humans are just subject to
his every women desire God Zs you're
right Jacks we should have a brand new
adventure for our new member pomy I said
that like 5 minutes ago however the
humans don't necessarily want to go on
these adventures and they're constantly
trying to find ways of getting out this
has even driven some of them insane
leaving them abstracted where they
devolve into monsters case in point the
clown kofo was obsessed with finding the
exit and abstracts just before pomy
shows up oh K's been obstructed it's
okay what is that and yet even when pomy
does get herself to the exit in this
pilot episode it doesn't go anywhere
it's just end hallways and office spaces
repeating it is basically the back rooms
as it turns out Kane made this fake exit
hoping to give the humans what they
wanted he just didn't know what to put
on the other side I do have to apologize
for lying about the exit I was having so
much trouble figuring out what to put on
the other side and ended up never quite
finishing it and more or less that's
where we leave the colorful cast of The
Amazing digital circus after this first
episode now already there's just so much
World building here for us to dig into
so many questions posed that we want the
answers to to like who's behind the
amazing digital circus is there an
actual way out or they just trapped
forever are characters like kmo really
gone or can they be brought back in some
way and uh sorry to say I don't have a
whole lot of answers for those things
not yet for as much as glitch and Goose
Works packed into the first episode
they've done the wise thing and not
given us a whole lot of answers but I do
think they've given us plenty here to
theorize about so here are three amazing
digital circus theories don't run for
the exit doors yet my friends we're
going in let's start things off a bit
small scale here Theory number one
everything in the show is literally a
video game set in the late 1990s now
there's a lot in just this one episode
that paints this as a video game world
for example right at the beginning we
see a pixelated title card for the show
that's obviously in the style of old
school PC PlayStation and N64 games this
is further driven home in a secret video
that you can find if you go to Wacky
watch.com a URL shown on screen during
the episode which shows us the main menu
for this game we also see a flower pot
fall to the ground and clip into it kind
of like an old school Source engine
glitch Kane mentions that he created the
Digital World in the weird back rooms
office area in a way that's very similar
to how a game developer would create
World spaces plus when pomy first enters
the world she says this I put on some
weird headset and now I'm here again
directly implying that the whole thing
is a game she put on a VR headset and
was transported into the world with the
digital circus all of that checks out
and should be pretty darn obvious to the
Casual viewer but what you might have
missed is the fact that this is set in
the late 1990s and not the present day
like you might expect from something
talking about using V R headsets and
there is a lot of circumstantial
evidence that points us to this
conclusion first of all basically all
the tech that we see throughout the
series seems to be pulling straight from
the 9s anytime we see a computer in the
show it's always the white boxy styled
CRT monitors and large white computer
towers reminiscing to models made by
companies like Dell and Gateway back in
the '90s and early 2000s and this is
both in the actual episode and in the
off-site material as well in that same
wacky watch commercial we see a real
life computer with the same old school
design what's more the beginning of this
wacky watch video says that this was an
old old tape recovered on a date that's
censored and given the degradation on
that tape implies that not only is this
video old but was also recovered in the
past as well but this goes beyond just
the tech that's used in the series many
of the characters and iconography from
the show are very reminiscent of popular
characters and ideas from the late '90s
and early 2000s pom's gesture design
takes a lot of cues from sega's old
nights in dream series Jax shares design
inspiration and a similar name with Max
the rabbit from the salmon Max Games
Bubble clearly takes cues from Super
Mario's chain Chomps Jax and gangle were
both inspired by characters like Poppy
the performer an old Japanese 3D
animated series volcane and the digital
circus setup Fair reminiscent of the
villain and plot of I have no mouth and
I'm a scream a short story by Haren
Ellison adapted into a point-and-click
adventure game in 1995 anyway you slice
it it's very clear that the creators
want the show to have the same '90s vibe
that we're all so nostalgic for right
now but you might be thinking hold on
they're talking about VR headsets here
that's a modern thing right when this
thing just be inspired by the 1990s
rather than set in the 1990s that's a
pretty good call out a lot of advances
in virtual reality technology have only
been made across the last decade
especially when you're talking about
gaming that doesn't mean that VR
technology didn't exist back in the
1990s and I'm not just talking about the
rudimentary black and red wire frames of
the Virtual Boy either back in 1991 Sega
announced the Sega VR in 1993 virtuality
created the mega visor display and in
1995 Fort technology hit us with the
vfx1 headset just to name a few and
looking into Old footage of all these
things it doesn't look too dissimilar to
the sort of world that we see in the
amazing digital circus simple flat
textures rudimentary shapes and polygons
there's not a lot of detail here but
that's for good reason these headsets
they couldn't handle a lot of detail
true story I actually have some firstand
experience with these rudimentary
headsets the Great Lake Science Center
in Cleveland Ohio actually had a special
exhibit on VR technology in its basement
when I was a kid and it blew my mind
with the amount of wires and cables
these things took to run it felt like
you were jacking into the Matrix and you
had to wait 45 minutes to put on one of
these headsets but all of a sudden you
were dropped into a video game it was
simple I was walking through a purple
field with a bunch of bunch of green
triangular mountains in the background
but it was effective and it captured my
imagination for decades since so much so
that even though it was a 5-minute
experience that happened in my life like
two decades ago I still remember it
vividly to this very day anyway madpad
childhood story is aside the long and
short of all of this everything that we
see in the series is pointing to this
taking place in the past and not in the
present all of this has already happened
from our perspective we're just watching
the events of the game unfold so now
that we know that we're in a 1990s video
game here let's dig a bit deeper shall
we Theory number two humy helped create
this hell simul that they're currently
stuck in it's a pretty bold claim so
what would make me say that well a
couple of things firstly one of the
scenes that really jumped out to me
while I was watching and rewatching the
pilot was the sequence where pom's
running through the back rooms on the
other side of the exit door at one point
she enters a more traditional looking
office space with computers and cubicles
before stopping and staring at one desk
in particular this is played as a big
moment we Linger on this shot for a long
time as a classic horror esque Dolly
Zoom hits both the desk and pomy before
she has herself a psychological break
the lights start to flicker and she
cackles uncomfortably before running on
the whole thing is really menacing and
off-putting and clearly meant to leave
us with a big impression why well
because this desk isn't just some
simulation that Kane cooked up in the
back rooms it's based on a real place in
the real world of this universe outside
of the simulation a place that we
actually see in the episode at the very
end right before the credits roll we
zoom out of the circus and through the
void revealing that all of this has been
taking place inside of a computer that
makes sense we've already established
that this right here it's a big old
simulation but take a look at the
computer and the desk it's the the exact
same setup that we saw earlier in the
episode in the back room section the
same old equipment on the left the same
file cabinets on the right the same
retro Monitor and keyboard and computer
tower and speakers the same VR headset
and headphones this is exactly the same
but clearly this one's in the real world
not only have we literally zoomed out of
the computer implying that we're no
longer in said simulation but the
lighting in the scene is much more
natural it's warmer sunlight is
streaming through the nearby window all
at an angle because the sun's lower in
the sky this is not the flat computer
simulation lighting that we've been
seeing throughout the rest of the
episode that right there the desk and
computer setup existing both in the
simulation and in the real world is
already a pretty interesting point but
why then would it break pomy what causes
her to go off the deep end and start
laughing well I think that
subconsciously pomy recognizes that this
this is her desk at the beginning of the
episode they make it clear that pomy has
lost her human memories but this I
believe is triggering a deep realization
inside of her based on what we're given
here I believe that pne's human Persona
is an employee at CNA the company
developing the digital circus game and
VR headset and seeing it here inside the
game un some weird flash of her memory
as to what's happening to get her into
the situation she's trapped in the very
game that she helped to create it's
ironic hence why she laughs it's funny
it's Darkly funny I can see this being a
huge reveal down the line and one that
could be potentially devastating for all
the rest of our characters for pomy
obviously but also for all the other
characters who are trapped in here who
would be seeing her as the one to blame
for their current imprisonment also real
quick super short micro Theory I don't
think we have enough information to
figure out what the initials in the
company named c and a stand for but one
possibility that did jump out to me it
could potentially stand for Cain and
Abel partially named after the AI ring
leader of the simulation Cain which
could then lead itself to a lot of
interesting story possibilities you see
Cain and Abel are a pair of brothers who
are the sons of Adam and Eve with Cain
ultimately killing his brother and
creating the first ever murder in the
world anyway you know how we love
ourselves a good Biblical reference here
and I just wanted to mention it in case
we get more clues in future episodes but
something we do have more than enough to
say about Theory number three all the
characters aren't actually humans
trapped inside the digital circus
instead they're all digital copies of
the brains of humans who've put on these
headsets cloned and then forced into the
simulation now this is a pretty big
swing I mean pom's first line of the
series is practically oh no I'm a human
who put on a headset and now I'm trapped
here and then Kan follows it up with
this my my it appears a new human has
entered this realm human he calls her a
human and that actually lines up with
what we've seen with the official
synopsis explicitly calling pomy and the
others humans in contrast to Cain being
an AI quote from that synopsis a woman
gets trapped in a crazy virtual world
along with five other humans and are now
subject to the whims of wacky Ai and
their own personal traumas plus I just
personally like the image of a bunch of
people strapped into these VR headsets
Allah swordart online but all of that
being said I believe that there's a lot
of evidence pointing towards these
characters being computerized clones
rather than actual humans for instance
as I mentioned above pomy starts going a
bit crazy when she sees her desk from
The Real World in the circus's back
rooms but think what was actually on
that desk a headset pretty clearly a
headset that is not on any human's head
and that's not just a thing in the
simulation it's also on the desk in the
real world too that we see in the final
shot of the pilot if there's a human
trapped in the digital circus here with
a headset firmly planted on their head
that they can't get off shouldn't they
you know be stuck there with the headset
on their head given the little that we
have to go off of right now it makes
more sense that pomy put on the headset
had her Consciousness copied into the
game and then she just took off the
headset to go home meanwhile pomy in the
game can't take it off because she's is
not a flesh and blood human anymore
she's a digital copy whose memories
begin the moment the headset was put on
and even if we're wrong and this desk
isn't pom all the other characters went
through this exact same process when
they first joined as Jax's hinted at
when he sarcastically said how do I take
this headset off just keep grabbing at
it that works for all of us they all
tried the exact same thing and it didn't
work for any of them they're all digital
copies grasping at a VR headset that
isn't there anymore but you know the
thing that really convinced me of this
Theory the mannequins yeah did you
notice these guys all throughout the
episode we see several artist mannequins
populating the circus you know these are
the things that artists will sometimes
buy to help him get references for poses
most prominently we see him in the
restaurant with Kan and bubble acting as
background characters but why would they
matter well we know that Kane can create
NPCs Kane is this one of your NPCs or is
this a new sucker so maybe these
mannequins are just random nameless
characters that Kane made up to fill in
the circus maybe but that just doesn't
sit right with me first off the dolls
are clearly capable of emot itions we
see one get upset when pomy interrupts
at taking a bath silently screaming at
pomy until she slams the door there's
something more going on here than just
these things being background extras
take a look at this when ragi is showing
pomy to her room there are several other
doors for other characters in the
background this is actually a great
piece of World building we see that each
of the current characters have
themselves their own rooms as well as
several other characters that we haven't
met yet there's this colorful one that I
can't quite make out what looks to be a
pinkish purple goo monster some sort of
cute doggo green and orange ante eater
looking guy a black queen chest piece
that I'm going to guess is named Queeny
seems to be Ker's counterpart implying
that he didn't come into the simulation
alone regardless all of these portraits
have giant red x's over them and that
checks out these are likely characters
that have abstracted in the past just
like kfmo did we even see other
abstracted creatures in the cellar when
cane banishes cough mode anyway along
with these past and current characters
we also see several doors with blank
mannequins on them not just one but
multiple doors if I had to guess what's
going on here when a new human enters
the game these rooms trans form into one
that's appropriate for them and the
mannequin on the door transforms into
their character and what's more I
believe that there's a mannequin in the
game that also transforms into that
character right now they're placeholders
but they get molded into these human
copies whenever someone new puts on the
headset and their brain gets scanned
into the system that would fit
thematically with the idea of the
mannequins to begin with they're
supposed to be used as references and
then turned into something real when
you're using them for your artwork that
would also fit with the fact that
they're on the doors of all these empty
rooms and the characters being scanned
clones of human bra brains would fit the
fact that they can't take off their
headsets despite us seeing a headset not
being worn at a desk that is clearly
meant to be pomes it just all fits with
what we've seen from the series so far
in short the series is gaslighting us it
isn't about a bunch of humans trapped in
a simulation it's about a bunch of human
consciousnesses that have been scanned
into an AI system and then mapped onto
blank mannequin bodies where the
computer can then simulate their human
behavior and push their buttons to the
breaking point learning the weaknesses
of the human psyche and then when
they've had too much and Abstract out of
the system well then you just boot up
another new simulation and try again
there is no exit door just an endless
loop of torturous tests run by Kane as
he tries to understand The Human
Experience just like a real circus all
of it is just a big performance but hey
you know a character in the show that I
think is criminally underrated bubbles
this adorable little bubble doggo seems
like they're willing to eat just about
anything but I know for a fact they
would absolutely love the food from the
sponsor of today's episode Sunday's dog
food if youve follow the channel for a
while you'll know that I've always been
more of a cat person but a lot of Team
theorists are dog owners and absolutely
adore their furry friends and so when I
told them about Sundays they loved what
Sundays was all about why wouldn't they
be Sundays is basically the best dog
food in the digital Multiverse unlike a
lot of other brands all of Sunday's dog
food is human grade you see the whole
company was started by a vet who wanted
the food her dog ate to be as nutritious
as a real home-cooked meal that means no
hyper processed chemicals or synthetic
vitamins if you look at the label you're
actually going to be able to pronounce
everything that's going into Sundays
because it's all the stuff that you're
already likely eating yourself and
unlike other Healthy dog foods Sundays
requires no prep no defrosting and no
cleanup all it requires is a dog to
enjoy eating it which honestly shouldn't
be that hard it's already hardcoded into
the game system for example one of our
team members Rachel volunteered to let
us film her pup Stevie trying the food
out for the first time the results just
really speak for themselves look at this
even though Stevie is super shy around
new people as soon as we broke out the
Sunday she really opened up and
basically started drooling despite all
the new faces with cameras and just look
at her go into that food I'm not sure
I've ever loved anything I've eaten
quite as much as this dog is loving that
Sundays if you want to give your dog
this awesome vet created dog food made
from real ingredients that you'd
actually find on your own dinner plate
you can get 35% off your first order by
clicking the link in the pin comment
below and then using our code film
Theory a checkout once again that's 35%
off your first order by going to the
link in the pinned comment below and
then using the code film Theory at
checkout f i l m t h e o r y thanks
again to Sunday for sponsoring this
episode and as always my friends
remember it's all just a theory a film
Theory and
cut